Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassam Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassam Namo tassa bhagavato hara-hatto samma-sambuddhassam
homage to the Buddha the blessed noble and fully self-enlightened one so we're still going through these Kanda so just to remind you that Kanda means heap or aggregate bits and pieces all stuck together we started off with Rupa which was the body itself and
really what we were looking at was how the mind experiences the body and that's where we came across these four great elements fire earth water and air then we looked at sanya which was basically the perceptual base how it's turned into little percepts how labels are put on things and how later these are the basis for our intellect
then we looked at Vedana which was the feeling content and there were two types of feelings those created by the body and those created by the mind in the body and how these will now congregate to form our emotions
So the fourth element is this sankhara.
Now sankhara is used in a very wide sense by the Buddha.
We chant sabbe sankhara nityati, the morning chant, sabbe sankhara dukhati, sabbe sankhara anatati.
All compounded things are impermanent, unsatisfactory and not-self.
So this Sankara means all compounded things, it's the phenomenal universe.
So there's nothing substantial there, it's all made up of bits and pieces.
which through the magic of the mind take on a certain substantiality.
So we know that anyway from our science.
You walk into a door, it hurts, but we know it's made up of subatomic particles.
In fact, it was the meeting of one set of subatomic particles with another set, as simple as that.
but in the khandhas it has a more specialized meaning it has those sankhāras which are within the mind itself within the mind when I say mind here remember it's the heart and mind so when I write about this I usually use the word psyche to draw them both together in our older language medieval language it would have been the soul
So Sankara there is the passive side which we can talk about our habits or dispositions.
They are the platform upon which we then behave into the world.
so that when they become activated we call them, they're normally translated as volitional formations volitional formations so what we're talking about is our thinking and emotional life and the reason why the Buddha separates this out from all the rest of this psychophysical organism is because here is where the will is active the rest are given
Your body gives you the sensations and you can't do much about it.
The mind has its own way of perceiving things and you can't do much about it.
It's often dependent on our culture, frankly.
and feelings just arise because of the makeup of the psychophysical organism.
But here with sankhāda, this is the world we're living in, in a much more direct way, and it's governed by the will, governed by what we intend to do, and through our thoughts, our actions, our speech, and that's where we get these volitional conditionings.
Sometimes you get writers trying to find suitable words.
Sometimes in its passive sense, I've heard it being translated as preparation, which doesn't quite work for me.
And in its active sense, I've heard it translated as concoctions.
So it's a difficult word to translate because it has both its passive meaning and active meaning.
But
From the point of view of our liberation, from the point of view of creating a beautiful world for ourselves, it's the place where the will is active.
and our meditation now just before I say that remember that the khandhas are a snapshot of the psychophysical organism if you take a moment this is what you'll find it doesn't tell us much about the process the process of the psychophysical organism is expressed in the Wheel of Dependent Origination and the Sankara are really that middle bit
which includes the reaction to things the tanha and the grasping of it as I want and then the empowerment of it which there is known as becoming
but here is included in the understanding of Sankara so these Sankaras are really where it all happens for us where we actually you might say experience life and the point of Vipassana is to take the unpleasantness out of those Sankaras you see so it's not as though the Buddha doesn't have habits but he's not governed by them anymore and they're all beautiful
that's the difference so we also have beautiful sankhādas but there's a lot which aren't so beautiful in the Buddha's way of looking at things of course a lot of them have to do with our ethical behavior so that brings a certain quality of morality to our behavior too
and the whole point of our vipassana is to eradicate everything that's unwholesome within us which is established in these sankharas so that brings to the end my little homily on sankhara I hope it has been of some assistance may you be liberated from all your negative sankhara sooner rather than later
Sadhu, sadhu, sadhu.